- I think it's time we
the scientifically
challenged and concentrate
on one of science's
heroes, Tyler Bradt,
kayaker extraordinaire.
He wants to kayak over this,
Palouse Falls in Washington.
Thousands of cubic feet of
water pass over this fall
every second and drop 186
feet to the pool below.
To consider kayaking
over this, he must either
be a few sandwiches
short of a picnic,
or a world record breaker.
We hope.
[music playing]
Oh.
There he is, the
new world record
holder of one of the
most dangerous stunts
I have ever seen.
Needless to say, even if you do
have a 186-foot water feature,
don't try this at
home or anywhere else.
Falling off a waterfall
is the easy part.
But as gravity initially
accelerates you down
at 32 feet per
second per second,
it's surviving that's
the tricky bit.
Our kayaker must go over the
falls at the correct speed
to give gravity just
enough time to generate
the angular velocity needed to
rotate the kayak 90 degrees.
This angle minimizes
hydrodynamic drag,
so he experiences
less impact force
and cuts through the water.
It's also worth noting
that a kayak's stability is
dependent on keeping
the center of mass
in line with the
center of buoyancy,
which is in the middle
of a submerged volume.
Otherwise.
OK.
Science-taught, let's see if
our team of want-to-be record
breakers have learned.
He's practicing the science with
a man-made kind of waterfall,
but the law of
gravity is the same.
The thin layer of water
acting as a lubricant
combined with the steep angle
allows gravity to do its thing.
It's not quite the
32 feet per second
per second of a
waterfall freefall,
but he's only practicing.
On to angular velocity, or
in this case, the lack of it.
Launching too fast meant he
gained very little angular
velocity, hitting H2O
at a terrible angle,
thereby maximizing
hydrodynamic drag.
Which is bad, as it brought him
to an almost immediate and very
painful stop.
Waterfall.
Check.
Angular velocity.
Stability.
Check, ish.
It's an upside down check,
but technically he still got
himself into a stable position.
It's just a shame
his center of mass
is directly below his
center of buoyancy,
as his head is the thing
he uses to breathe.
Cheering without
acknowledging the person
that just saved your life.
Check.
Even if our want-to-be record
breakers do get to grips
with angular velocity,
hydrodynamic drag,
and stability, like Tyler did,
186 feet is just too dangerous.
Maybe it's better to kayak
somewhere safer, like a puddle.